trois dossiers qui peuvent se
concrétiser rapidement le premier une
négociation directe entre la sncf et
alstom sur un train qui est exploité par
la sncf qui fait paris turin 1 1
milliard milan aujourd'hui ils ne se
sont pas mis d'accord
gd invite à se mettre d'accord je fais
tout pour sauver le site de belfort un
plan d'urgence
c'est ce que c'est ce que tente de faire
françois hollande en étant marchands
d'illusions parce qu'en vérité
les coûts de production sont élevés les
commandes publiques sont insuffisants
c'est tout un plan stratégique à refaire
rien pas de stratégie industrielle
depuis tant d'années pourquoi une
surcapacité de production à alstom
aujourd'hui qui est réel mais c'est
parce que depuis des années la france a
abandonné le fret ferroviaire parc c'est
quand même assez incroyable qu'on dise
pas des choses aussi simplement que ça
mais quand on est actionnaire principal
d'alstom
on ne peut pas feindre de découvrir bon
qu'on va faire mais aussi des sports
dirigé fixé l'objectif
l'objectif c'est d'assurer la pérennité
du site de belfort
alstom pour les prochaines années pas
simplement pour les deux ans qui
viennent
non pour les prochaines années parme et
en même temps coup de tonnerre à belfort
les salariés d'alstom reçoivent ce mail
de la direction sans équivoque
malgré les efforts de tous il apparaît
aujourd'hui impossible d'assurer un
avenir pérenne pour les activités du
site de belfort paris le mans la
direction d'aston ne l'entend pas
vraiment la même oreille que wilson
semble déterminé à fermer le site de
belfort parce que c'est un bras de fer
avec le gouvernement il s'agit d'essayer
en tout cas il peut pas y avoir deux
bras de fer puisque ce site restera
sera pérennisée et j'ai le sentiment
qu'un certain nombre des déclarations
qui ont été faites ce matin ne sont plus
à l'ordre du jour le communiqué qui
avait été envoyé et à communiquer
anciens docks c'est une erreur de
communication
des discussions sont engagées avec le
gouvernement et rien n'est définitif la
situation peut évoluer
voir défilé de politiques au salon de la
coiffure hier à paris après la visite
classique d'alain juppé bruno le maire
s'est improvisé coiffeurs aux stands les
sages brésilien monsieur macron s'est
fait raser vous vous coiffer alors c'est
ça oui moi je préfère avoir le pen entre
les mains envoyé pour diriger les
opérations
trois jours qui préparait la vente mais
moi il en mémoire ce que disait ce que
disait alors si la campagne
présidentielle c'est ça tremblait quand
même ça va être très très longtemps
c'était prévu en communication
alors merci de ce wagon
je viens de la primaire le 27 novembre
et qui après rendez vous en mets toi
aussi tu as dû vous servir pour la
présidentielle et qui sait quand on voit
ce que coûte un coiffeur présidentielle
vous savez je me dis que c'est peut-être
bien savoir sur quoi ces choix mais main